[Musique]
ce mercredi 21 septembre au palais de la
source a été dévoilé la trajectoire
réunionnaise 2030 un nouveau pacte de
développement pour la réunion le
président Cyril Melchior ainsi que les
vices présidents du département ont
présenté à la presse les grandes lignes
de ce projet qui a notamment pour
objectif la performance institutionnelle
76 ans de dépendante mentalisation on
produit des effets positifs mais il
reste des problèmes à traiter et c'est
parce qu'il reste des problèmes à
traiter que nous voulons proposer un
projet à l'horizon 2030 ou à la réunion
nous avons besoin d'une loi de
programmation sur 15 ans pour fixer le
cap de ce que nous voulons pas la
Réunion et je le dis le département
prendra toute sa part à réaliser ce
projet réunionnais aux côtés des autres
institutions cela passe par la
décentralisation de décision pour faire
en sorte que les décisions soient plus
prises plus rapidement de mots le débat
institutionnel n'est pas nécessaire ça
sera un écran de fumée nous ne voulons
pas des grandes fumée nous ne voulons de
la clarté la trajectoire réunionnaise
2030 priorisent également l'accès à
l'emploi comme levier d'amélioration du
niveau de vie comment faire que plus de
pouvoir d'achat soit donné aux
Réunionnais cela passe par la création
d'emploi l'éloignement pose
nos handicaps l'éloignement nous avons
l'exécuté du tissu économique qui fait
qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment d'emploi
mais si on est là aussi
le champ d'action de notre économie à
travers l'économie bleue
la Silver économie parce qu'il y a des
possibilités de création d'emploi dans
les métiers d'aide à la personne et bien
si on élargit l'éventail des emplois
nous allons pouvoir offrir à chaque
jeune réunionnais et une possibilité
d'un session professionnelle active
réaffirmer la position de la Réunion
dans la zone Océan Indien tout en
mettant l'accent sur la coopération
voilà aussi l'une des ambitions portées
par le Département quand on dit qu'il
faut développer des circuits courts cela
passe aussi par la possibilité
d'acquérir d'acheter des produits dans
les pays de la zone Océan Indien quand
vous achetez des menuiseries venant
d'Afrique du Sud ça coûterait moins cher
30% moins cher par rapport à ce qu'on
importe aujourd'hui pas tout à chacun
sera gagnant à la matière c'est pour
cela que nous voulons d'une bonne
intégration de la Réunion dans sa zone
Indian océanique avec possibilité
d'acheter donc des matériaux dans les
pays de la zone le nouveau pacte de
développement trajectoire réunionnaise
2030 détails bien votre proposition
comme les laboration d'une stratégie
régionale d'économie verte et bleue ou
encore la promotion de l'excellence et
de la résilience réunionnaise
[Musique]